the Academy is proud to welcome a
two-time Oscar
the distinguished actor producer who
brings honor to the family name mr.
Michael Douglas
the Academy's Irving G Thalberg award is
limited to creative producers whose body
of work reflects the consistently high
quality of motion picture production of
course this is not presented every year
but this year the Board of Governors
unanimous choice his an honorable
gentlemen who exemplifies the motion
pictures academy support of independent
filmmaking he was once my partner he is
still my friend and I'm proud to say his
name Saul Zaentz
in 1975 Saul and I produced One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest Mueller
schwarmann directed it for us Jack
Nicholson starred in a won five Oscars
including Best Picture well we thought
it was beginner's luck but Saul went on
to win another Best Picture and seven
other Academy Awards for his second
collaboration with me lotion Amadeus
Saul's passion for reading writing and
rhythm led him into the recording
business where he just completed his
42nd year with the company he built into
the largest jazz label in the world and
while his devotion to jazz continues
unabated his appetite for assembling the
elements of epic moviemaking and
shepherding them through the writing
shooting editing marketing and
distribution continues to give us
distinguished films like the ones you're
about to see ladies and gentlemen Saul
exacts
thank you Michael
25 years ago we worked together and he
hasn't forgiven me since for yelling at
him but that's show business I'd like to
talk to for a minute about passion don't
move around in your chairs or change the
station on your TV set as the following
words we'll be innocent Darryl zanuck
Hal Wallis David Selznick Walt Disney
and Samuel Goldwyn are among the Giants
who were the early recipients of this
award all are recognized as producers
who brought passion to their films and
they were really bound together by their
love of moviemaking
passion is unmeasurable indescribable
factor that separates movie from movie
passion moves freely across borders
speaks every language and flourishes in
every culture the movement of passion is
the most gratifying satisfaction in any
movie makers life this happens when you
see and hear people all over the world
share their laughter their crying and
their sudden gasps at identical screen
moments
Samuel Hoffman Steen a poet and
screenwriter poetically wrote the holy
grail is not in the finding it is in the
journey the Irving Thalberg award
memorializes a giant among Giants who
brought us a sense of film history this
belongs to the many with whom I have
shared dreams and journeys my cup is
full thank you
after these messages Celine Dion
the oscar-nominated songs and Sigourney
Weaver and Kristin Scott Thomas will
also be joining the 69th Academy Awards